[Music]
we often hear about genes only when
something goes wrong
when mutations mistakes made in the dna
sequence
cause a disease like cancer or cystic
fibrosis
but what happens inside our cells that
leads from a mutation in dna to the
physical symptoms of a disease
why do some mutations cause positive
outcomes or no change at all
to answer these questions we take a
closer look at how information flows
from genes
to rna to proteins to all the physical
structures and processes that make up
living things
you might ask yourself what are the
relationships between genes and proteins
this is such an important concept for
biologists that we've dabbed at the
central dogma
the central dogma essentially explains
how biology works
the central dogma explains how the
instruction in dna
are converted into proteins and the way
this is done
first the rna polymerase reads the code
in the dna
and turns it into messenger rna mrna is
very similar in structure to dna
except that it is single stranded the
mrna then leaves the nucleus
and goes out to the cytoplasm of the
cell
there it finds another set of proteins
and it's a large protein complex
made up of about 70 different proteins
plus additional rna molecules
this complex molecule is called the
ribosome
the ribosome decodes the message that's
on the mrna
and converts it into a protein so the
central dogma explains this whole
process from the stored code to a
message to a protein
and the proteins are who do all the work